let's see if we can compute what 1.86
divided by 2 is
and like always pause this video and
have a go at it and i'll give you a hint
see if you can think about
1.86 as a certain number of hundredths
and then divide that by 2.
all right now let's work through it
together so as promised let's see if we
can think of 1.86 as a certain number of
hundredths so if we go to the hundredths
place we only see six there but we could
view eight tenths as 80 hundredths so
you could view the 0.86 as 86 hundredths
and each one is a hundred hundredths so
we really have
186 hundredths so this number right over
here i'm going to rewrite as 186
hundredths
hundredths
and that is what we need to divide
by 2.
now if you're dividing 186 of something
by 2 well it's just going to be 186
divided by 2 of that something so we
could rewrite this as 186
divided by 2
and then that's the number of hundredths
this is going to be so i'll put that in
parentheses so it's going to be that
many hundredths
100
all right
so what is 186 divided by two
some of you might be able to do it in
your head some of you might wanna might
wanna use some paper the way what i like
to think about it is if i were to take
the six ones and divide it by two well
that's going to be three ones and then
if i were to take the 18 tens and
divided by two that's going to be nine
tens so that gets us to 93.
now you could have also thought about it
like this you could have said how many
times does 2 go into 186 let's see it
doesn't go into 1 how many times is
going to 18 9 times 9 times 2 is 18 we
could subtract and then you have 0 you
bring down that 6 2 goes into 6 3 times
3 times 2 is 6 you subtract and you get
no remainder so either way you're going
to get 93 and it's 93 what what's 93
hundredths
is what we're talking about 93
hundredths
and now we just want to express 93
hundredths as a decimal well how do we
do that well that's going to be zero
point
the 90 hundredths is the same thing as
nine tenths and then the three
hundredths is of course three hundredths
three in the hundredths place so it's
0.93 and so we could write it up here
this is going to be equal to
0.93 and we're done